what did you like most about what's been
announced today and what was missing in
your view if anything so I think the
thing that is really encouraging about
today is that there is an ambitious plan
beginning to be put in place for the
economy post brexit and in the context
of globalization and technology change I
think that the we really like the fact
there's an emphasis on region we really
like the fact that there is still an
important place for sector because we
have the success from automotive and
aerospace to know that approach works
but we also like the emphasis on
cross-cutting skills and infrastructure
the thing I think that we need to see in
the next few months in the consultation
is action and delivery because this is a
report with a hundred pages and it does
cover 10 pillars an awful lot of ground
prioritization and focus and we'll be
looking for a real partnership with
business to make sure the right
priorities are taken forward isn't the
problem though that there isn't an awful
lot that seems particularly new about it
I mean identifying strong sectors isn't
particularly new Vince Cable did that
with the automotive and aerospace
industries during the last government I
think we don't necessarily need
completely brand new ideas I think what
we do need is joined up thinking and
joined up planning across government and
business so I think you're absolutely
right Ian to to highlight the successes
of the past and last year we talked
about the contrast between a ton of two
sectors the steel sector where there
hadn't been joined up thinking and a
strategy which was clearly you know very
challenged and automotive where there
had been so I think we can draw on the
lessons of the past I think there are
some new things here I think the
emphasis on region the emphasis on what
government is calling place and they've
really really important emphasis on
technical skills so it's something the
CBI has been talking about for a long
time the vocational training and
particularly in the context of digital
change and robotize ation and AI we are
going to need to get better much better
and rescaling the next generation isn't
the implication and all this so that
fewer people are going to go to
university in future that they're going
to have to do technical apprenticeships
instead I think one of the things that's
quite interesting
the emphasis that government's placing
on creating a kind of balance of esteem
I think that's a very worthwhile
objective so that there are two really
really viable tracks for for young
people to follow that don't have a kind
of sense of one being better than the
other when I go around talking to
businesses the the areas of skill
shortage are in technical skills they
are in engineering they are in in lab
technicians where you know for example
Cambridge has just run out of so we know
the economy has a need we know we have
young people who want fulfilling career
paths I think this is a real opportunity
to bounce them up know I guess another
problem is that that just isn't enough
money available at government level to
put any of this into practice I mean
it's very much looking to the private
sector to do the heavy lifting
financially here well I think that is a
real challenge which is why I go back to
prioritization and delivery being the
challenge for the next stage and we're
looking forward to working closely with
the government regionally and by sector
because absolutely right there needs to
be prioritization I also think though
that business across the country is
ready to stand up and lead and invest
for example we're going to start some
work on how more funding could be
crowded into infrastructure investment
for example we think there's plenty of
appetite for that and to start
coordinating that I think is a private
sector opportunity could the regional
peace be boosted if you encourage more
competition between regions allowing
them to sense different levels of
Taxation for example I think that the
idea of different differing levels of
taxation is one that's worth looking at
but I think we need to be careful
because one of the great things about
the UK at the moment is it is a single
market and ease of business across the
the country is very important but I
think what's also true is that we know
that regions differ greatly we've just
done a big piece of work at the CBI on
differences in regional productivity and
I think there are real opportunities
from the prize of devolution we have
metro mayors coming in later this year
and the opportunity to think differently
particularly actually about local skill
levels and joining up universities and
businesses to make sure we have the
right skills going going into those
businesses so regions are different I
think tax we need to be careful about so
if you have to give great clock and
treasom a and mark out of ten for this
Oh high marks I mean I think that the
comprehensive approach the idea of
needing a plan putting it in the context
of the antidote and then respond to the
brexit really really welcome it's now
about delivery and execution and it
needs to be a partnership between
business and government and I guess a
key thing not to do is to start giving
money to individual companies as was
done back in the 70s I think the great
thing here again is that sectors are
still there as a priority but the idea
is there'll be sector deals sectors will
have to come up with their own plans and
certainly from the businesses I know
they are absolutely keen to do that but
know it's not about handouts the
business is about to joined up plan for
the hold economy